I'm back all right folks I'm excited to
talk about this movie today The
Wolverine starting Hugh Jackman damn
look at that body I rewound like a six
thousand calorie diet for this film I
can see why after you get a body like
that gosh she just want to lick him yeah
bet you do pervert so how is this
performance I'm gonna be as straight to
the point as possible here wow that's a
total a chef it's the best Wolverine
performance we've ever had find out for
yourself why it's so fantastic it's got
all the layers you want at this time
this time you really get to know his
identity he gets to find himself yes
he's not just lost again and the movie
doesn't end again with him being lost or
you see him go through a whole journey
and and then he hits a bullet in his
head and something if just forgets
everything we saw that that wasn't a
waste of my time one thing that I know
is on everyone's mind he has bones that
come out of his hands right before their
adamantium can you do that with his
penis and yes it delivers all the goods
the action the effects are fantastic
it's not fun party with effects but when
it's there it's pretty [ __ ] good and
the action is awesome what schools like
every action scene has its own little
flavor to it and there's this fantastic
scene when they're fighting on top of a
speeding bullet train not a speeding
bullet a train and let me tell you i
thought that scene was gonna suck when i
saw the trailer I was wrong that made me
[ __ ] in a good way you ever heard of an
orgasm poop that is what I had and then
this one you know its key it feels
violent cuz Wolverines really [ __ ] up
people in this one this other character
they called Yukio she she has an
interesting shaped head there is
something about her head that is really
distracting I've heard it described as a
Tim Burton type of character had a heart
shaped head
here why don't you come below and tell
me what you think of her head but
speaking of head I would not want this
moment to give me hat cuz she seems like
she can kill me at any moment meeting of
EU afraid for my tennis she's a great
supporting character for Wolverine would
I do stuff with her nah I love this
story telling of this film Thank You
director James mangled when I first
heard darren aronofsky was gonna do this
movie I was like whoa get ready for the
most depressing Wolverine movie we are
about to see and james mangold something
I was like I know these of the better
director than aronofsky necessarily but
he delivered it i love the overall tone
I love the themes that are going on I
love how they had this story of
Wolverine who's this guy who really just
wants to die it's cool to see an
immortal who's suicidal and is really
dark they made a much darker this time
and he has to go on this journey in a
foreign country a fish out of water and
he has to find himself you know learning
the ways of the samurai and that is just
cool it's like the last samurai needs a
good x-men movie and that's another
thing to actually it doesn't necessarily
feel like an excellent movie it feels
like its own standalone film you're not
there bored going we're only watching
One X Men you are so pulled into this
one person tail it's fantastic you gotta
just watch it for one simple reason it's
better than x-men origins wolverine
x-men origins wolverine that movie I
could pee on the light on fire and I've
done that several thousand times I
negative in my bank account from the
amount of dvds aya peed on every reason
that origin sucks the creators of this
new one they said hey uh we know what
sucks and we are gonna make it good and
they succeeded by the way there's a
wonderful production design but I know
you don't wanna hear me spend too much
time on that because you might zone out
you might get bored and this is supposed
to be entertaining for you because it
was me entertaining I can't talk about
production design for too long all I can
tell you is it's great it's fantastic
fantastic is like the word to describe
this movie you know there's a couple of
things though that that are not so great
about this film they got a Viper she she
horrible actress don't like her mmm the
one watch anything else she's in maybe
I've seen her attorney I'm gonna pee on
those movies
she was just way too cartoonish from the
very beginning I I felt like she thought
she was in a completely different movie
just bad just she was the first thing
like 45 minutes into this movie that
pulled me out of the film and yes
everybody critics are complaining about
the third act and when I saw no like
yeah I see all the flaws here it gets a
little bit bombarded it starts to speed
up and it gets wait so the way to
science fiction a little too cartoonish
and I see that but there was also some
cool stuff in there and it wasn't enough
to make me go [ __ ] this movie is despite
parts of the third act despite this
[ __ ] I still love the film immensely
well let me get straight to the point
here oh no I got it saying the Wolverine
got it super right alright guys thanks
for checking out my show why don't you
go ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me what did you think of the
Wolverine and I haven't seen it is it
because of x-men origins wolverine and
if you want to go ahead and follow me on
twitter you can click this link right
here we can talk back and forth to each
other we can tweet each other would be
cool man be cool we could smoke a bowl
over Twitter together and if you want to
see a more in-depth review up the
Wolverine go ahead and check out my show
called reasons to see that I do my buddy
Jerry and we're going to give you a good
ultimate in-depth spoiler review of the
Wolverine a lot at least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
is up go ahead and click on this button
do subscribe that's right near the
crotch area the wolverine is what i like
to call it because it's quite bushy